Prime Minister Abbey admin was sworn
into office in April 2000 18 since then
the 43 year old former army intelligence
officer has launched a wide program of
political and economic reforms such as
ending state monopolies and allowing
private sector competition in industries
such as telecoms aviation and power his
biggest success so far was the peace
deal with neighboring Eritrea ending a
nearly 20-year military stalemate
following their two-year border war in
June last year the Ethiopian government
agreed to hand over control of the
disputed border town of Padme to Eritrea
until then if he Opia rejected the
international boundary Commission's
ruling in favor of Eritrea it's
unpredictable style isn't popular with
all EcoP ins
the most Ethiopians trust him the only
problem they have right now is they
wanted the change to happen immediately
we have a lot of economic problems in
this country although the economy is
growing very fast the amount of
expenditure that going into
infrastructure has been at the expense
of livelihoods he played a central role
in the violence fight against illegal
land grabbing activities in the Oromia
region four years ago the government
stopped a controversial scheme in 2016
but disputes continued and resulted in
people being killed that fight is seen
by many as boosting at mitts political
career he's from their aroma tribe
Ethiopia's largest ethnic group which
spearheaded the protests that forced his
predecessor to resign an assassination
attempt two years ago failed to stop his
development plans for Ethiopia an
activist a military intelligence officer
a land grab opponent an unpredictable
politician a peacemaker and now a bee
ailment can add Nobel Peace Prize winner
to his list of accomplishments dorsa
Jabari al-jazeera
let's bring in hallelujah Lully he's a
political analyst and head of Ethiopian
Foreign Relations strategic studies
that's a political think-tank thanks for
speaking to us
on the NewsHour I think I know the
answer to your to this question but just
give me your initial reaction to this
win well it was somehow expected but the
reaction I think was overwhelming people
are not just taking this recognition as
a recognition to Muhammad as a Prime
Minister of Ethiopia but people are I
mean if you do a proper analysis of the
streets of Addis if you look at the
Twitter and Facebook sphere people are
taking this as a recognition to what the
country has achieved in the past Syrian
half and the resilience of the TPN
States and its people in their ambition
in realizing their ambition for an
inclusive and accountable State you have
a human rights organization analyst
international saying that Prime Minister
aphids work is far from done and this
award should push and motivate him to
tackle the outstanding human rights
challenges that threatened to reverse
the gains made so far do you think that
these gains that have been made or under
threat and does amnesty have a point
JTP an estate has a very long history of
authoritarianism and a transition to
democratization is going to be a very
bumpy one and it's a cognition that abu
hamid has made are different occasions
what has been done in the past syria in
half i believe are laying a very solid
foundation in building independent
institutions because what ABI I might
say for example is I mean he released
thousands of political prisoners but the
key is not just about releasing them but
building independent institutions an
independent system that will prevent the
possibility of any political prisoners
in the future so it's a still a work in
progress but I believe what has achieved
so far in the past Syrian have has been
very impressive and this win especially
now coming at this specific moment will
be will serve as a tempest to continue
this ambitious project of democratizing
to Penn State and liberalizing the
political space but Ethiopia still has a
very real struggle with
ethnic tensions as well as millions of
internally displaced people how
challenging is the year ahead going to
be for Prime Minister Ahmed as he
tackles those challenges oh well you
know it's a very difficult task he's
tasked with this very difficult
assignment of being inclusive and being
unifying at the same time the more your
inclusive you know the possibility of
having contradicting voices within is we
would rise so but one of his I think
flagship you know his ideology so far
has been can be summed up with one maxim
it's called madam ER it can be roughly
translated as synergy so he's been
preaching national reconciliation and
cohesion among the different ethnic
linguistic and religious groups in
Ethiopia and actually he's made
significant progress and achievement in
you know narrowing the gap between the
different interest groups in Ethiopia of
course we still have a long way to go in
creating you know in reaching the very
strong and sustainable Elliots pact and
political settlement but I think his
rhetoric has resonated with a lot of
Ethiopians who want peace reconciliation
unity and prosperity in this country
okay hallelujah losely thank you very
much for speaking to us from Addis Ababa